Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to play with a cellular
automaton and fuse it together with a neural
network.
It will be quite an experience!
But of course, first, what are these things
anyway?
You can imagine a cellular automaton as a
small game where we have a bunch of cells,
and a set of simple rules that describe when
a cell should be full, and when it should
be empty.
What you see here is a popular example called
Game of Life, which simulates a tiny world
where each cell represents a little life form.
So why is this so interesting?
Well, this cellular automaton shows us that
even a small set of simple rules can give
rise to remarkably complex life forms, such
as gliders, spaceships, and even John von
Neumann’s universal constructor, or in other
words, self-replicating machines.
Now, this gets more interesting, a later paper
fused this cellular automaton with a neural
network.
It was tasked to grow, and even better, maintain
a prescribed shape.
Remember these two words, grow and maintain
shape.
And the question was, if it can recover from
undesirable states, can it perhaps..regenerate
when damaged?
Well, here, you will see all kinds of damage…and
then, this happens.
Nice!
The best part is that this thing wasn’t
even trained to be able to perform this kind
of regeneration!
The objective for training was that it should
be able to perform its task of growing and
maintaining shape, and it turns out, some
sort of regeneration is included in that.
This sounds very promising, and I wonder if
we can we apply this concept to something
where healing is instrumental?
Are there such applications in computer science?
If so, what could those be?
Oh yes, yes there are!
For instance, think about texture synthesis.
This is a topic that is subject to a great
deal of research in computer graphics, and
those folks have this down to a science.
So, what are we doing here?
Texture synthesis typically means that we
need lots of concrete or gravel road, skin,
marble, create unique stripes for zebras,
for instance, for a computer game or the post-production
of a movie, and we really don’t want to
draw miles and miles of these textures by
hand.
Instead, we give it to an algorithm to continue
this small sample, where the output should
be a bigger version of this pattern, with
the same characteristics.
So how do we know if we have a good technique
at hand?
Well, first, it must not be repetitive, checkmark,
and it has to be free of seams.
This part means that we should not be able
to see any lines or artifacts that would quickly
give the trick away.
Now, get this, this new paper attempts to
do the same with neural cellular automatons.
What an insane idea!
We like those around here, so let’s give
it a try!
How?
Well, first, by trying to expand this simple
checkerboard pattern.
The algorithm is starting out from random
noise, and as it evolves…well, this is a
disaster.
We are looking for squares, but we have quadrilaterals.
They are also misaligned.
And they are also inconsistent.
But, luckily, we are not done yet.
And now, hold on to your papers, and observe
how the grid cells communicate with each other
to improve the result.
First, the misalignment is taken care of,
then, the quadrilaterals become squares, and
then, the consistency of their placement is
improved.
And the end result is, look!
In this other example, we can not only see
these beautiful bubbles grow out of nowhere.
But the density of the bubbles remains roughly
the same over the process.
Look!
As two of them get too close to each other,
they coalesce, or pop.
Damaged bubbles can also regrow.
Very cool!
Okay, it can do proper texture synthesis,
but so can a ton of other handcrafted computer
graphics algorithms, so why is this interesting?
Why bother with this?
Well, first, you may think that the result
of this technique is the same as other techniques,
but it isn’t.
The output is not necessarily just an image,
but can be an animation too!
Excellent.
Here, it was also able to animate the checkerboard
pattern, and, even better, it can not only
reproduce the weave pattern, but the animation
part extends to this too.
And now comes the even more interesting part.
Let’s ask why does it output an animation
and not an image?
The answer lies within these weaving patterns.
We just need to carefully observe them.
Let’s see.
Yes, again, we start out from noise, where
some woven patterns emerge, but then, it almost
looks like a person who started weaving them
until it resembles the initial sample.
Yes, that is the key!
The neural network learned to create not an
image, not an animation, but no less than
a computer program to accomplish this kind
of texture synthesis!
How cool is that?
So, armed with all that knowledge, do you
remember the regenerating iguana project?
Let’s try to destroy these textures too
and see if it can use these computer programs
to recover and get us a seamless texture.
First, we delete parts of the texture, then,
it fills in the gap with noise, and now, let’s
run that program!
Wow!
Resilient, self-healing texture synthesis.
How cool is that?
And in every case, it starts out from a solution
that is completely wrong, improves it to be
just kind of wrong, and after further improvement,
there you go.
Fantastic!
What a time to be alive!
And, note that this is a paper in the wonderful
Distill journal, which not only means that
it is excellent, but also interactive, so
you can run many of these experiments yourself
right in your web browser.
The link is available
in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!